يجدر القول ان رونالدو هو اللاعب الاكثر
شعبيه في هذه الرياضه ويحظى بسهوله باضخم
قاعده معجبين بين جميع اللاعبين في العالم
لكنه ليس لعب كره قدم محبوبا فحسب بل هو
ايضا رجل اعمال ذكي منذ ان كان في مانشستر
يونايتد انخرط رونالدو في صفقات تجاريه
عده في اشاره الى شركته الاسطوريه سي ار 7
فقد اطلق عطورا وظهر على واجهه العاب
الفيديو المرتبطه بالكره القدم ويمتلك خطه
التجاريه لصناعه الالبسه الداخليه كذلك
لديه علاماته التجاريه في مجال الملابس
رونالدو ما هي رائحه كريستيانو رونالدو
حسن في الحقيقه احب دائما ان تكون الرائحه
جميله وهذه تجربه الثالثه هذا العطر
رائحته ناعمه وخفيفه
ويمكنك ان تتخيلي كم انا سعيد فالرائحه
فواحه لا اعرف اذا شممت رائحه العطر اذا
انه نعم انا احبه كثيرا واصبح اكثر من
لاعب كره قدم خلال عقدين من الزمن صار
تقريبا علامه تجاريه بتلك الوقفه الشهيره
قبل تنفيذه ركله حره على اعلانات عطور سي
ار 7 والمتحف في جزيرته في ماديرا وكل ما
يحيط برونالدو وقد اعتنق ذلك فهو رجل
استعراضي ورجل اعمال محنك وهو يفهم حتما
اهميه موقعه ضمن نجوميه العالم
ما الهدف من الاستثمار في هذا المشروع حسن
في الحقيقه انها فرصه كبيره وجميله
فالمجال الصحي يعنيني كثيرا علينا بذل كل
الامكانات والجهود للاستثمار في هذا
المجال
وشريكي ايضا يساعدني ويعجبه هذا المشروع
وهو شخص لديه رؤيه عالميه وانا سعيد جدا
بشراكه معه انه مميز وعلاوه على ذلك يقدم
الكثير من الدعم للمجتمعات الفقيره منذ
عام 2014 عمل رونالدو بالتعاون مع منظمه
سيف ذا تشيلدرين لمساعده الاطفال الذين
عانوا من الحروب او اصيبوا بامراض خطيره
في ارجاء العالم كذلك صار سفيرا للمنظمه
وواصل اجراء الحملات لهم في شكل منتظم
[موسيقى]
كما يتبرع رونالدو بمكافاته الكرويه
للجمعيات الخيريه التي يختارها عام 2013
تمت تسميه رونالدو في صفوف فريق العام
للاتحاد الاوروبي لكره القدم وحقق له ذلك
89 الف جنيه تم تقديم هذا المال مباشره
الى جمعيه الصليب الاحمر الخيريه كذلك نال
مكافاه قدرها 450 الف جنيه تبرع بها لسيف
ذا تشيلدرين واليونسيف